hey US don't press monies I'm having one
of those relatable days
I don't know how relatable it is I fell
off the skateboard my pants broke
so I'm sitting without pants and I
stepped in dog [ __ ] all at the same time
in one move and it's just having a
really bad day and I just I just need to
record a video and you bro suggested cat
Mario for cuz apparently someone from
the pits of hell thought that that was a
good idea the spikes are lethal I know
this look at that [ __ ] coins [ __ ] you
I'm not gonna fall for that
that coin let me you mother I'm not
pissed that's fine I'm happy bad things
happen to good people
you [ __ ] I hate everyone and I hope
everyone dies a horrible death can I
take these I can okay you just gotta get
speed all right watch me do this [ __ ]
cat Mario's paw
look at me shaking my Teddy a puppet of
it but dip it boom ah I can't trust
anything don't wanna close my eyes I
don't wanna fall asleep [ __ ] you spur
dumpling sperm double sperm we haven't
seen that [ __ ] since 1984 exit
checkpoint right now how do we do this
okay I'm gonna trust the coins what are
the codes they're not even counting I'm
gonna trust you to coin and you chew I
you know what I bet you look at this
[ __ ]
yes yes yes oh you spiky [ __ ] [ __ ] is
that [ __ ] is your [ __ ] problem man
I'm just gonna go for it oh my god I
just had to go for it okay notice Oh use
cloudy [ __ ] [ __ ]
alright we got I don't rap what is this
I don't trust this this game is the
reason I have trust issues please don't
kill me don't kill me
don't care
what it was that easy video games
oh my video games was not in can I
finish my [ __ ] sentence video games
was not video video games there we go I
have no soul I'm dead inside
iron felt an emotion since the first cat
Mario my elbow oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god no no no keep doing it cat
Mario keep doing it I love you yeah
komaraiah
ah
jump here jump here don't forget about
the cloud and number three is gonna [ __ ]
me in the ass [ __ ] me then there you go
you [ __ ] if there's one more I swear to
God
bring it I can't jump on these I know
it's a troll oh my god it's the wrong
day it's the wrong day to do this
there you go you fell down you did it
Lord Bray
Oh bread Lord bread please give me
strength
whoa